is the zoom call being recorded too yeah
it says it's being recorded up there i
mean i've never recorded a zoom call but
you should i don't know if you guys can
see up in the top left corner of the
screen there's there's a recording
symbol there maybe
yeah it says recording good okay
great um all right so
i don't know listener or viewer
if you are watching us on the tubes or
if you're listening to us
on audio this is our first time trying
this out
uh we have with us a guest who will soon
be introduced
interestingly our guest is a colleague
of the dad of our podcast uh
dr jordan b peterson
that's not a great way to introduce me
by the way
you are technically technically
colleagues i i i could see that point
but
it's not how i would prefer to be
you know but anyway okay
well i'm sure the esteemed the esteemed
jungian will come up at some point he
always does
he's like our our foil anyway um
he's fine as a foil it's just as a
colleague i'm a little uncomfortable
understandable technically a colleague
all right
so we have us with us uh you're hearing
or
seeing uh professor ronnie biener
who is going to be introduced by my
colleague
victor politics guy yeah
so um professor ronald boehner is a
professor at the university of toronto
in political science he is he's focused
on political theory and he's the author
of numerous books including uh
political philosophy what it is and why
it matters civil religion a dialogue
on the history of philosophy and most
recently and kind of the impetus behind
this podcast
is a dangerous minds nietzsche heidegger
and the return of the far right
so maybe we could begin uh professor
boehner and you could tell us a little
bit about
the main thesis of the book what you're
trying to accomplish in the book
okay well uh the background is pretty
clearly
the rise of the far right or the
resurgence
of fascism or various forms of
fascism light which we're seeing all
around us all kinds of
crazy new ideologies that are popping
out of the woodwork and it's something
that we have to
contend with quite seriously as citizens
um
i guess i started getting i developed my
interest uh in the far right actually
early in 2015 and
as at that moment just things started
becoming more
and more worrying and they started
really getting alarmed
as many people did in 2016
uh with brexit with the election of
donald trump
with other versions of right populism
and i felt some kind of inner need not
so much as a theorist but
as a citizen to warn fellow
fellow citizens about uh the ideological
ferment
uh on the far right and it was deeply
shocking to me as i started exploring
far-right websites that people who are
very uh sometimes extremely
well-educated
uh with phds phd's in philosophy
uh and and considerable
intellectual equipment being drawn back
to the
you know the breeding grounds of 20th
century fascism in the 1920s
and it's as if well here history is
repeating itself you know
uh what was called the conservative
revolution
in the 1920s well it's back and
we have far-right uh presses like arctos
devoted
to resurrecting these people you know
this the
the the spanglers and
and the uh uh ernst youngs and the
and the schmitz and and and it's like
cranking the
cranking history up again to produce a
kind of similar outcome maybe with some
tweaking uh you know the fascism of the
30s a little bit
so that it's maybe less
you know egregiously violent or less
genocidal but in terms of what's driving
it intellectually the sense of a liberal
egalitarian
civilization as decadent from top to
bottom
and requiring a radical
surgery or radical overthrowing that
that project
is kind of back in business um
uh one would have hoped and it's
certainly the hope at the
latter decades of the 20th century that
fascism had been permanently deposited
had been so utterly discredited by what
we came to
know in 1945 that been permanently
deposited in the rubbish bin of history
well turns out that wasn't
the case and it's a deep shock to find
out it's
it's it's it's not the case i mean it
was in the news yesterday i think that
most uh most high school students
in the united states don't know that six
million
jews perished in the holocaust
how can you have a kind of historical
blind side a blind
spot of of of those proportions
if if historical memory is that short
and that uh unreliable
and that fickle well we're in real
trouble so here we are 75 years later
and we can't count on people knowing
how evil fascism is and and what what
perils
uh you know lie for all of us in in its
resurgence
and you know uh so i became a bit
obsessed
and i remain obsessed it's been like for
five years now
with cern intellectuals who are
as i said highly educated happy she's in
philosophy
and have hyper
energy megalomaniacal energy
which they put into and they have
technical skills to build websites and
develop
large numbers of followers uh
you know people like richard spencer
he's more familiar name greg johnson
runs a website called counter kurtz
jason giorgiani
teamed up with spencer to form an
alt-right corporation uh
you know these people are all extremely
smart and they're all extremely
dangerous and what does it say about the
world we're living in
that they're putting massive energy into
rebooting fascism dispensary of a phd
masters started he started he has a
master's from the university of chicago
he has a bachelor's degree from the
university of virginia
and he started a doctoral program in
history
uh at duke he
pulled out of it and became a kind of
editor
and you know uh for far-right
periodicals so he didn't complete his
phd
there was some rumors floating around
that he had been expelled
i don't know if those ruperts are true
he had the equipment to pro
probably have a phd
he studied with a friend of mine michael
gillespie uh
at duke today took a nietzsche seminar
there apparently took a nietzsche
seminar at the university of chicago
with robert pippen
that kind of was the start of all this
and
claimed that you know this is what he
was read killed by nietzsche to use his
famous phrase
uh this opened his eyes to the decadence
of a liberal egalitarian society
and he wants to resume the nietzschean
project of destroying a liberal
egalitarian civilization and ronnie
you're you're making this sound really
bad and you've mentioned spencer
bad guy folks but he's been totally
de-platformed and
has disappeared at least to me someone
who pays at least
elliptical attention to this sort of
[ __ ] but you're making
not just right-wing politics but actual
fascism
sound far more diffuse and far more
widespread so is it it is it is more
can i just throw in an anecdote here
because this is actually quite funny um
i actually met victor brazoni uh
politics guy
at a party uh at my den apartment in
2016
where we were all gathering together to
watch donald trump go down in flames
and victory remember this because uh he
was like do you think you know clearly
clinton's gonna win i'm like oh yeah
it's a sure thing and he was like
yeah i think so too everybody in this
like podcast
was there and we were all stunned
like just glued to the tv at 2 30 in the
morning and we had a couple of
like whiskeys and stuff and we were like
is this actually happening like i just
can't believe it
no we had to go and get more whiskey if
i remember correctly yeah we did we were
like well this is
apparently going to be a longer night
than we all thought it was and
that actually sparked my interest in a
lot of these phenomena as well because i
just
couldn't understand how something like
this could happen in
the 21st century right it's not supposed
to happen it seems like that had
been relegated as you put it to the
rubbish bin of history uh
here it was again yeah and then the
search for the silent majority began i
guess
yeah i so i i won't say that i wasn't uh
shocked and stunned by the election of
trump of course i i
was but the the real true
shock said in when he brought
in steve bannon as his senior accounts
that's when the
red lights really started
flashing uh i mean a colleague of mine
political science i think the day
after the election said to me or maybe
it was two days after the election
said to me well the real test of where
this is going is what happens to steve
bannon
if if trump brings bannon
into the white house then we're all
[ __ ]
the whole world is [ __ ]
observation by you know various duke
political scientists made a big
impression on me and then sure enough
you know a week later trump announces
bannon is going to be a senior counselor
uh you know
senior senior advisor with an office
right next to the oval office
now bannon is a fascist we now
know this um he's not
that's not the i would call him a coked
out [ __ ] first
okay you can you can call lots of things
but powerful
in terms of the topic being discussed
here what matters is
his involvement in and his
fascination with and his i'd say
you know complicity with fascism or the
project of
re rejuvenating or
resurgence of fascism so we now know
this very
clearly so someone who i've had some
contacts with uh someone who teaches the
university of colorado
boulder uh named benjamin title bomb
published a book
in the spring guys uh on bannon
called war for eternity and um
uh and i've had some communications with
title bomb as he's writing the book he
spent the last few years
having a long conversation with bannon
you know
running after band and all over the
world and having long interviews with
him as well as other people with
lots of power lots of access to
high power in brazil and russia and now
in the united states
uh and and tracing these people's
intellectual
sources where where they're coming from
intellectually
well there are some pretty shocking
revelations
in this book i'm very surprised bannon
you know made these
uh confessions to title bomb i don't
know why he did it
but you know there's a much there he
dropped hints along the way
that he had a kind of fascination with
julius ebola well jewish of all of them
you know prided himself on being well to
the right
of 20th century fascism including nazism
they did you know he can
uh uh fashioned himself a
an aristocrat and fascism was supposed
to be a movement to
you know put uh aristocracy back in the
driver's seat as
nietzsche wished it to be and and so for
him
you know fascism actually existing
fascism was
still too populist to democratic
to egalitarian so he thought you know
he saw himself as to the right of
fascism
uh anyone interested in julius evola
though the kind of
alarm blood belts start flashing and
not just that but apparently one of the
most
dangerous fascist ideologues you know uh
on the scene today still living ebola's
dead he died i think in 74 but still
living is alexander dugan in russia
bannon apparently had an eight-hour
meeting with dugan in
rome in the in the fall of 2018
and we now know that we didn't know it
at the time but now we know it thanks to
title bombs book and
it you know uh bannon says to him
uh to title bomb how much he admires
doing
so yes well i you know i admire muslim
brian you know you might as well be
holding up a placard saying i am a
fascist
this is someone who had an office right
i mean
not for four years for it was seven
months a little bit more than seven
months but still an office next to the
oval office in the white house
and ronnie if your friend told you um
that this
where steve bannon would go would be the
indication of of the future
and the fact that he got ousted you know
not immediately but almost immediately
what is that does that give you more
hope for the future then given the
thesis you're presenting here
i i'd be hesitant to count any of these
people out so you can say
well uh spencer has fallen on hard times
he can't even
pay you know a lawyer so that's good
news so
you know the more spencer's legal and
financial problem the better for the
world
and the same way couple weeks ago got
arrested aboard a luxurious yacht owned
by a billionaire friend of his
uh so good you know so he's got problems
it's it's
you know he's had the significant
setbacks
but you know bannon keeps popping back
up he kind of has nine lives
and yeah uh i wouldn't say well
i mean if if trump gets reelected on the
third of november
he can uh bannon and pardon all kinds of
other
kind of thugs and criminals uh so
he would never do that oh yeah so i
actually was wondering
i was wondering if maybe just from the
perspective of political theory and also
for
the listeners we've been you we've been
throwing the word you know fascism
around and i think maybe it would be
useful just to
to get like uh maybe professor biener
you could tell me like how would you
define
sort of like philosophically or like the
main tenets
of fascism and if you could establi
elaborate on something else you said in
in keeping with that you said
fascism is aristocratic but
i'm not a political theorist but fascism
has always been a middle-class movement
in
in my in my pedestrian understanding of
political theory
well what something presumes to be and
where
it draws its popular support can be two
radically different things so we have to
keep that in mind
but yeah i agree we need to kind of back
up a few steps and
and uh i i you know i need to fill in
more of the picture about
what what the book's about and how how
it proceeds and
and and what it's trying to engage with
uh theoretically so
you know most the bulk of the book is
i mean there's some discussions at the
beginning
about some of these uh contemporary
uh far-right characters like richard
spencer and then some reflections at the
end
uh about the historical moment and how
worrisome it is
and the perils of contemporary liberal
democratic citizenship but the bulk of
it in the middle
it's a dialogue with nietzsche and
heidegger which
might seem a bit strange uh although
all these people put a lot of emphasis
on how much they
including spencer how much they owe to
nietzsche and heidegger these are heroes
of all these
figures on the far right and i don't
that's an accident
and i think it obliges us to take
another
hard tough look at you know
nietzsche and heidegger and their
cultural
philosophical influence in you know
in contemporary culture and the
contemporary academy
so i think nietzsche is very helpful no
either we know was a fascist in the
sense that he joined the nazi party in
1933
uh he resigned the position he had
assumed as director of fryeburg but
he never relinquished his party
memberships on that sense he was
just until the war ended in 1945 and
i have i think substantial reason to
think that
his political sympathies remained where
they were before the defeat i mean
you know if if if the war had gone the
other way in 1945
he would have remained you know a uh
uh you know an adherent
of of far far politics
then the nazis lost the war i mean he
was critical in various ways of the
nazis fine
but he never tore up his party
membership so that's pretty telling in
nietzsche's case
well he could have been fascists because
he died in 1900 and the fascists
you know fascism started in the early
20s
and and and reigned in italy and germany
in the 30s so
in italy in both in the 20s and 30s and
40s
so nietzsche i think is a crucial figure
you can't call him fascists because
fascism didn't exist
but you can you can certainly call him
proto-fascist now people
resist that and think that's unfair to
him
i i don't think it's unfair again the
the people who composed the conservative
revolution in the 1920s in weimar
germany
they were all ardent nations
uh including heidegger and uh
and and and younger and and uh spangler
and all these people they and they had
there it was i think
there was in it was on the basis of
certain insight into what nietzsche's
project is
so what is that project
well i would say that the
the um key issue
with respect to the meaning of political
modernity
is here where one stands towards the
french revolution the principles of the
french revolution
uh that was a kind of egalitarian
cultural revolution
in the west it's taken for granted now
it's the it's some broad sense the basis
for
the air we breathe morally and
politically
uh nietzsche regards the french
revolution as
a catastrophe for the west he spells
this out very very clearly
in the genealogy of morals and if
someone hasn't wrestled with that
i i think they're off the target we're
not seeing the the
you know the real picture with respect
to
nietzsche nietzsche's project
nietzsche's view is
that you know it's a disaster to
abolish hierarchy to abolish rank order
to abolish uh uh
inherited privilege all those things are
disasters that a civilization that
attempts to do that
will be not a civilization at all but a
faux civilization a full culture
that's what liberal modernity is and it
has to be destroyed
because human beings rather than
elevating us to a higher moral plane
it will be the cause of human beings
becoming less human
it is a dehumanizing cultural
event can i interrupt please uh sorry
one sec
um the french revolution was a
catastrophe for the west but
christianity was a catastrophe for the
west according to
nietzsche and if christianity is a
catastrophe then there is no west that's
being extolled in nietzsche so what is
the civilization that you are
uh referring to in reference to
nietzsche
that's not that's not the case i mean uh
the the westin begin with christianity
the ba the voice began
with paganism yeah i i know that but
then
if you're saying that nietzsche is
trying to defend the pre-french
revolution west
then he's only defending like homeric
greece right
yeah i mean why is why is christianity
the you know the source of all evil
nature
why why is it the privileged target of
all of his
massive rhetorical energies you have to
really think hard about that if you
haven't answered that question you've
made no progress
in in a dialogue with nietzsche
uh it's the egalitarianism of
christianity
we're all brothers of you know children
of god we're all brothers
we're all equal and we're all creatures
of god and that's
that's the key to the the human status
is that god looks on all his children as
if they're
uh equal and that's the you know that's
the moral center of christianity well
it's that moral center
that eventually gave rise to the french
revolution
you know via first the reformation then
the enlightenment and then the french
revolution it's a kind of
inexorable trajectory drawing the
conclusions uh you know out of
the the basic premises of christianity
that hadn't yet been
drawn but were inevitable if you found
your civil
civilization on a religion like
christianity
that is committed to human equality
as the core principle of course no
society's ever you know
succeeded in you know achieving these
egalitarian aspirations but the question
what are the principles
and that's what nietzsche is addressing
so for our listeners
um if you've if you've listened to our
episode on nietzsche
um this is us talking about um
the opposition between what nietzsche
calls the slave ethic
which he sees the egalitarian principles
springing from
and the aristocratic moral
ethic which he sees as the what we're
referring to here as the
sort of hierarchical idea that nietzsche
prefers and nietzsche does give examples
over history rome is a big one but also
the vikings the samurai
the homeric greeks he gives a spattering
of examples
sagas he loves his icelandic sagas
anyone who slaughters on a whim
is really in in nietzsche's uh good
books but he he has this
it's a test of your willpower you have
we have to be tested
whether we can do certain things without
flinching
and the fast you know fascism can do
that
it it meets that test people die
in large numbers blood gets spilled like
rivers in the streets
and a human being who can uh
do these things and not flinch
and christians don't and and liberals
don't and
you know children enlightenment okay
richard spencer doesn't want to
establish like an
icelandic nomadic raiding society though
i wouldn't
there's this amazing um sorry there's a
speech that um
heinrich himmler gave to the ss i think
it was in late 1942 but it might have
been in 1943
uh where he makes exactly the kind of
point that you're iterating uh ronnie
uh where he says many of you are gonna
feel truly bad about what you're doing
and that's to be expected and it's a
testament to your humanity
but you need to realize that compassion
to the present is cruelty towards the
future
and you need to have the willpower to
carry out this great project of
extermination
essentially right and it does invoke
this idea that this
mastery of will to do what must be done
uh is a moral virtue
uh that's characteristic of nazism and
that
elevates it above the kind of more
squishy
um political ideologies out there that
aren't willing to do what must be done
by
exterminating uh all the people who
don't belong
and it really it does kind of resemble
what you're talking about in some senses
right this idea of being a warrior
able to fight able to kill uh without
feeling remorse or pity
and the nazis were more self-consciously
neat again than
you know nietzsche's a fan base in the
contemporary academy
would ever want to acknowledge you know
in the book i discussed
nietzsche going to hitler hitler going
to the
nietzsche archives in weimar uh presided
over by
hitler's sorry
nietzsche's sister who ran the archives
and you know warmly embracing each other
and then takes along a state
photographer
and gazes up at a big bust of nietzsche
and you know this is moments of hitler
you know communing with the great uh
proto-fascist philosopher nietzsche is
preserved for posterity why well hitler
wanted to say well we you know we
fascists we we take philosophy seriously
and we see ourselves we're not just you
know it's not just the kind of
expediency or opportunism
this is principles where we are
committed to certain principles and
nietzsche was the
the one who articulated those uh
principles you know
the bolsheviks they have karl marx we
have frederick nietzsche
sent mussolini a copy of nietzsche's
collected works
could you elaborate those principles
ronnie just for our audience
well that's what i think i've been doing
the last
five minutes that that you have to
build your political culture on
hierarchy
on on top down authority
on an idea that that that social order
requires that
things move from from from top to bottom
that there has to be a great man at the
top an ubermensch
uh who legislates for
the rabble because if you leave the
rabble to themselves
you don't have order you just have
nothing you have emptiness
you have cultural you have the last men
which is which means kind of you know
just
sheer banality and that's intolerable
and human beings
this is the thesis human beings will not
tolerate this
they will i mean you could say that the
revival of fascism in the 21st century
is again a vindication of nietzsche
nietzsche was
there was no fascism ideologically at
all i mean there was anti-semitism at
the end of the
19th century but fascism as an ideology
didn't exist
and nature said well you just wait you
know wait a few decades
and you're going to have gigantic uh
ideological wars for
the control for the rule of the planet
between left and right and and you will
see
cataclysms that you've never seen in
human history
to to fight over burst or the principle
of
equality over versus the principle
hierarchy and we'll see what the outcome
is
and i will be famous because i predicted
those ideological wars well he was
totally right
totally totally right nobody you know
you've got to go read john stuart mill
there's no predictions of
20th century being characterized by
ideological wars where everything you
know the whole of europe will be
inflamed
over principles uh well nature predicted
that
i also predicted that he would be
heralded as
one of the greatest thinkers of his time
which you know that's right
sounds a little like he was totally
unknown but
lo and behold you know all these
predictions were right
and now 21st century again you could see
as a vindication of
of of nature that somehow there's a
dissatisfaction with
you know liberal polities
founding themselves simply on principles
of
decency and and prudence and
mutual respect and recognition of each
other's citizens
that's not you know nietzsche's claim is
that's not
humanly satisfying when heidegger was
enthusiastic about it he he sort of
talked about it like a renewal
of the german spirit he saw kind of in
fascism but
i think actually matt looks like he's
got something he wants i just wanted to
read this this is a quote from
mineconf that might actually iterate
what you're talking about uh
and obviously this is disgusting
language and uh
represents kind of abominable principles
so to our viewers you know i apologize
for invoking some of it but i think it's
clarifying where uh hitler says the
jewish doctrine of marxism
rejects the quote aristocratic principle
of nature
and replaces the eternal privilege of
power and strength by the mass numbers
and their dead weight
thus it denies the value of personality
and man contests the significance of
nationality and race
and thereby withdraws from humanity the
promise of its existence and its culture
as a foundation of the universe this
doctrine the jewish doctrine of marxism
would bring about the end of any order
intellectually conceivable to man
and as in this greatest of all
recognizable organisms the result of an
application of such a law could only be
chaos
on earth it could be only the
destruction of the inhabitants of this
planet
if with the help of this marxist creed
the jew is victorious over other peoples
of this world
his crown will be the funeral wreath of
humanity and this planet well as it did
thousands of years ago
move through the ether devoid of men
eternal nature
inextricably avenges the infringements
of her commands
now obviously you know i imagine that
nietzsche would be disgusted by the
kanji anti-semitism and
racism and nationalism and this but this
notion of an aristocratic principle of
nature
yeah uh how to be juxtaposed against
egalitarian doctrines in this case the
jewish doctrine of marxism
it does seem to kind of echo what you're
talking about yeah not even echo it
seems to directly
refer lines up and it's important to
know nietzsche also he you know judeo
christian he often lumped them together
and
as we see the heidegger black books
emerging too and
and and how far heidegger was into this
way of thinking
judeo christian tended to be something
they lumped together
hitler more so locked off the christian
part and focused on the jewish part but
really like like fascism what it's it's
anti-religious in general anyway
well there's a lot to be said there so
nietzsche and heidegger are very
different you wouldn't want to lump them
together
either was just a kind of garden variety
anti-semites as
we now know very clearly nietzsche was
more complicated
so he presented himself as
anti-anti-semitic
and he celebrated as a kind of maybe
even
phylosemitic although i think that's
going way too
far but there's a at a deeper level
there's a sense in which
the disgusting passage
you read from hitler and one should
point out there's a lot of disgusting
passes
yeah the nietzsche they're they're
genocidal passages in nietzsche i quote
them in my book
uh but with respect to anti-semitism
so at a deeper level
hitler's thesis is not that different
from
uh uh nietzsche's thesis because
nietzsche in his you know
insanely kind of stoked up polemics
against christianity puts tremendous
emphasis
on the jewish origins of christianity he
does that systematically
and and the ideas were where okay
the contemporary liberal west where did
that come from that came from the
egalitarianism of christianity well
where did that come from
well it comes from judaism and nietzsche
put a lot of emphasis upon that again
the genealogy of morals when he's
denouncing the french revolution you
know says well the ultimate
choices here french revolution versus
napoleon
uh the you know the the napoleon
represents the superiority of certain
great individuals and the french
revolution represents the opposite
well to say you get also the formula
judea versus rome
those are fundamental civilizational
choices
civilizational alternatives you have to
you can't go both ways
there's a fork in the road and you
either go with the romans towards
grandeur and will and the position of
one's
you know supremacy as uh
or that you know you go the jewish route
and
uh and and they there is a kind of
master thesis that the whole of the west
has been corrupted
by the jews via christianity
christianity is kind of like a middle
middle man in this narrative that that
where this is coming from
is more fundamental than christianity is
you know the jewish origins of
christianity well that's hitler's
that's hitler's thesis it's a
nietzschean thesis i mean
nietzsche can say yeah i hate
anti-semites they're just ideologues
i mean i think it's important to
point out that nietzsche unlike
heidegger was anti-nationalist
he hated german nationals and and
heidegger was a german nationalist
a very emphatic german national so
that's some real
or chasm between them but but
why is the anti-nationalist is the
anti-nationalist because it's a liberal
no no it's it's not illiberal enough
that he he wants you know a kind of
pan-european
vision because it's grander so it's a
nationalism versus imperialism it's not
he doesn't
side with liberalism over against
nationalism he sides with imperialism
over against nationals what what does he
emphasize about nationalism that he
detests
it's pettiness yeah right
it's weakness it's weakness it's taking
credit for other people's
unambitious oh and merely the germans so
what's
what's and why did the germans matter so
much what matters are the europeans
and beyond the europeans control of the
planet
so the nationalism is too limited in
its ambition i need to
at least get some elaboration on this
thesis because it's driving me nuts
because i disagree with it so vehemently
um first of all i want to go back way to
the
to the hitler quote the hitler quote
that nietzsche or that uh matt read
says this stuff goes from
uh natural aristocracy
to nationalism and race
so hitler makes that move quite fluidly
of course
nietzsche arguably never makes that move
and you could make a case that he does
but again like you said
this is what i was bubbling up inside
about he's a
vehemently anti-nationalist but now
you're going so far to say he's like
like a global nationalist wants the
ubermensch to conquer the world
whereas i don't see nietzsche or read
nietzsche at all
in that political sense because he far
talks
far more about music and art than he
talks about
politics i don't think he has a
political vision in mind because i think
he's writing for individuals and he says
as much in beyond good and evil i'm
ready for the individuals that are to
come
so i don't see this as we need a state
of people that will subdue other
people in a political manner or with a
political
project in mind i just think he thinks
that's a natural
result of that natural aristocracy which
again is
illiberal but i don't think he's
thinking that
this is like has really much to do with
politics at all
okay so i need to respond to that
uh we never promised no pushback
there will be a little pushback so uh
this is a very common reading of
nietzsche
it uh it's you know
very much to nietzsche's credit that he
induces people to read him in that way
and
mean means you know that people people
don't feel
nietzsche to be you know dangerous or
threatening
if he's you know if he's basically
non-political and is addressing himself
to individuals in a non-political
dimension i
i think that's a a
a a a reading that is far
too kind to nietzsche and doesn't
doesn't penetrate deeply into not into
enough it doesn't
train enough into what the nation
project is there is a project
and that project is political through
and through i would say that every
single
page in nietzsche including the one
pages you're reading is not political
are political plea niches political
through and through
beyond good and evil is a very political
book
i think you're kind of being captivated
by certain
you know certs within that book they're
leading you think well there's no
political problem
here but you gotta i think reread the
book or reread
niche in general and and with an eye to
what how political it is i can admit
there's a political project
if you mean political in a general sense
but you're talking about this like it's
a governmental or bureaucratic well
good and evil is is like the ruling
class ideology pretty much
he's referring to there right that's
what i would see it anyway good and evil
is christian morality good and bad
is is aristocratic morality so he's
really talking about like hegemonic
which is political from a culture
studies standpoint it's always political
he's talking about the hegemonic ruling
class ideas
right i think the question we're talking
about here then is is he talking about a
state or not and i adamantly disagree
or a culture or institutions here i have
a passage from beyond good and evil
that i think is illuminating actually
because it does talk about politics and
he says
beyond evil page 258 uh when for an
example an aristocracy like
pre-revolutionary france
tosses away his privileges with sublime
revulsion and sacrifices
itself to excess of moral feeling this
is corruption it was really only the
final act of that centuries-long
corruption that caused the aristocracy
to abandon
its tyrannical authority bit by bit and
reduce itself to a function of a
monarchy
and ultimately in fact to its ornament
and showpiece the crucial thing about a
good and healthy aristocracy however
is that it does not feel that it is a
function whether a monarchy or
of community but rather an essence and
highest justification
and that therefore it has no misgivings
in condoning the sacrifice of a vast
number of people who must for its sake
be oppressed and diminished
into incomplete people slaves and tools
and that's from beyond good and evil
where he basically says right an
aristocracy shouldn't even be concerned
with having a purpose
uh it should look upon the people as
slaves tools
uh and incomplete people uh
and that's you know kind of the be-all
and end-all you didn't say should in
there
you put the [ __ ] in and this is my
problem with this all things like you're
saying nietzsche is saying should which
he's an
a moralist doesn't do yeah but i think
here when he says a good and healthy
aristocracy right he doesn't really talk
in normative terms in term
and prescription yeah he's speaking
about the past but that's about that's a
moral claim
that's not a political project but but i
think this is one of the difficult
things about nietzsche's
like work right he's not a moralist so
he can't say you should do this but he
can't say a good and healthy aristocracy
that performs life-affirming functions
would do this and part of the problem is
the good and healthy aristocracy in
pre-revolutionary france
gave that up no that wasn't a healthy
that wasn't a healthy aristocracy
if it was healthy they wouldn't have
gotten to the point because they gave up
these privileges right they started
treatment no because they were resentful
this is why they this isn't this is not
to me political
at least a political project this is
just like
it's a psychological project even more
than that
okay i'll let ronnie speak because i can
see that he's eager to say something and
he's our guest of course but well
i think the disagreements are so huge at
this point it's hard to know where to
start i mean i'd go back to
what i was talking about at the
beginning of the conversation
if i'm right that the fundamental
core of nature's preoccupations uh
is the what what modern egalitarianism
has done to european culture and
that can be fixed culturally it has to
be fixed
politically to destroy the basic
dispensation of this that bequeathed to
us by the french revolution that
the destruction of that is is is not a
cultural project it is a political
project
and i think nietzsche's basic idea is
you know even if you say well what he
what he fundamentally cares about his
culture yeah that's right
but you can't have a culture within
egalitarian horizon and and to say it's
not
prescriptive not normative uh
that is i to me that's just a profound
misreading
every just like every patient each is
political well even more so
every page nietzsche is prescriptive
it's normative
uh it's you know the rhetoric is just
bursting with
a normative charge it's everything
everything in nietzsche is normatively
charged
he hates the world he's living in and is
screaming from the rooftops for people
to
realize how empty and and nihilistic it
is
and that the whole human status rests on
our
capacity to affect a revolution you
can't affect that revolution by speaking
individual to individual
i mean sure individual readers can read
his books but that's not what's
going to change the world he wants to
change the world uh to
to to to remove
the reigning dispensation which is a
fundamentally
post-christian post-enlightenment
post-reformation egalitarian
dispensation
and go back to aristocracy to say that
he does he's not
he you can't go back though that's what
he never ever says
that's okay we don't go we go back to
something even
more hierarchical even more
you know it's that uh
okay let's go forward to new well what's
what's going forward mean
going forward is going forward to
fascism no
well a a conception of hierarchy that's
non-christian
that's pagan i mean there's it's on
accident
that that you know fascists like you
know
uh julie savola or ellen de benoit
these people are pro-pagan for nietzsche
reasons
uh i should say ryan to have the kind of
politics they want they have the kind of
political horizon they want
it can't be founded on christianity it
has to be found on paganism
that's a nietzschean argument that's a
nietzschean vision and it's a political
vision
and um uh i mean you can say well okay
nietzsche was you know there were things
that separated nietzsche
from from the nazis i'm not saying well
he's full-blown nazi or he would have
like heidegger
got a membership card in the nazi park
if he was still around in 1933 i mean a
sister was a nazi but we can't hold out
against them
but but but in terms of the basic
preoccupations
that the choices here are living in a
fundamentally
within a fundamentally liberal cultural
political
moral normative dispensation
with no culture because he thinks that
cannot produce a culture
or something else something radically
illiberal
something radically a liberal
post-liberal and post-christian
uh well you're kind of then sliding into
fascist territory that's why i would
call his thought fundamentally
proto-fascist well you have a different
reading but we would have to go
like start reading you know beyond good
and evil page by page
i'm going to transcend my position and
this argument rather and then
shift it over to victor who sent me a
message a while ago that he wanted to
talk
yeah well i just wanted to interject and
say uh we split on exactly these lines
last time ronnie so don't yeah
in our nature episode we did the same
thing yeah
you know i can't expect to persuade
everyone there's no
modern culture is full of people who are
you know love nietzsche and i
used to love nietzsche myself i don't
even love nietzsche though
like i'm i'm a leftist but i don't like
nietzsche very much either anyway
sorry sorry victor before uh yes okay i
think it might victor sorry
first just it might be helpful to say um
like the reason maybe a lot of
resentment
comes up around nietzsche and even
heidegger too the supplies too is
because they have been
so sort of um central to the
institutional
left that's emerged in the post-60s
so i mean if you're if you're reading
someone like foucault
and you understand that he's derived his
method
from nietzsche's genealogical approach
to which is essentially a kind of
philology tracing words back to their
origins and
using them in a kind of developmental
historical argument
it can be a little bit difficult to hear
that nietzsche has
all of this dangerous side and and we
have to be very careful with him because
we've invested so much
in reading him and in many ways like
sort of rehabilitating him because we've
all heard the story about his sister and
how he's
how she kind of distorted his texts but
i think yeah like when we're so invested
in him intellectually and
not me but other people career-wise it
can be a little bit difficult to have
these conversations maybe so it's good
to keep that in mind
especially when we come from a more like
we're all maybe varying positions
on the left maybe i'm a bit more further
left than other people are here and so
nietzsche has played a big role in that
especially you know
in his in in that text about uh on truth
and falsity in the non-moral sense
that's a major
post-structuralist kind of proto-text
right so so these feelings do come out
and they're i mean they're good
it's i think it's therapeutic i'm i'm
very very
aware of this of course and that's why i
wrote my book
probably the biggest reason why i wrote
my book i knew i persuaded any right
nietzsche
so i didn't really write the book for
them i wrote it for
left nations to try to
persuade them that they've made a
gigantic mistake
put their money on the wrong horse and
and it's very disturbing
that uh you know three of the biggest
heroes
of uh the intellectual left in recent
decades
of being you know two fascists and one
proto-fascist namely nietzsche heidegger
and schmidt
uh something radically wrong with the
contemporary intellectual left when
you're going to the far right for your
intellectual sources and and you know
if if if fascism really had been
destroyed you know in perpetuity in 1945
so utterly discredited could never make
a comeback well fine
you know and then then you know
nietzsche heidegger and schmidt are not
dangerous in the way they might be
if the the right is making a big
comeback
which arguably it is and you know if i
didn't feel it was making that kind of
comeback i would not have
written or published this book it was
you know
we need to take another look at these
thinkers in the context of a big revival
of
the intellectual rights and
and and and you know leftists need to
take another look at nietzsche heidegger
and and ask themselves you know they're
really getting their sources from the
right place
i mean part of it is just sexual honesty
that you know
nietzsche is just not a uh thinker of
the left and never could be
you know 80 of his intellectual energies
are going into denouncing
equality uh uh
and and he you know he hates modernity
because it's too egalitarian how could
that be a source for the left
it just you know it's the most basic
question is you know the fundamental
choice here
is between our equality and hierarchy
and nietzsche is
the you know supreme theorist of
hierarchy
and he says it again and again and again
since
cultures that are not based on rank
order will not be cultures
and and you can't delude yourself into
thinking you have a culture
in the context of a egalitarian
dispensation
that's why you have to destroy the
french revolution and destroy
christianity and even judaism
judaism in so far as it led to
christianity
yeah absolutely destroy the
enlightenment certainly destroy the
reformation
this is you know this is where the
rights is coming from
that's why the rights not just leftists
who love nietzsche it's people on the
right you know
read you know go back to the 1920s
weimar germany and then look at some of
these websites
who are trying to revive all that and
they're niching for the same reason that
you know the spanglers and the youngers
uh yeah
and and and the schmitz were were
nietzsche yeah so i i so i had a
question
saying yeah victor has been i've been
waiting okay yeah so i'm
so professor i was curious about how you
see
like like liberalism itself as being
something because i think maybe in to
some extent
there's figures on both the right and
the left and maybe like the far left
right there's a kind of dissatisfaction
right with
with liberalism with i think you even
wrote a book in in maybe the 90s
called like something exactly
yeah so i'm curious about i'm now a
chastened critic of liberalism because
there are things
much worse than liberalism right right
so that should be obvious
you know in 1992 supposedly liberalism
had won liberal democracy had vanquished
all
ideological rivals and we could uh
follow
communism communism and the follow
and and the defeat of fascism and the
liberal democracy was
in the saddle and you know that was the
context in which i wrote that book
uh and uh you know
worries about liberal triumphalism i i
would say things very differently now
that the real threat
is liberalism being defeated by the
right um
that's that's that's the context for
this book in contrast with the 1992 book
i mean
there are different eras you know but
i'm curious if you have like thoughts
about how to
you know address because i think there's
war there's like a there's like seems to
be a hunger right on like the far left
and the far right
for something for like or a a
sort of a distaste for the way
liberalism right it creates uh something
that is experienced as kind of like this
this boring like non-life affirming and
i just wonder whether
there's something there's like you have
any thoughts about how to make
liberalism
address those things better or if you
see cap like maybe how you see
capitalism is potentially part of that
equation just the way like it doesn't
provide this like
life affirming as nietzsche would say
and i feel like that's a value
maybe to some extent marxists to some
extent marxists in a way
are like have similar complaints about
liberalism but like their answer is
obviously way different about just the
fact that it's
creating these impersonal social
relations right like there's a hunger
for real
like you know so whatever people want to
say quote-unquote real cultural or
social relations whether they're like
some sort of equality uh uh like in
marxism or this like hierarchical
like look up to somebody who's going to
show you what the values are and i just
wonder if you have thoughts about
about that sort of dynamic well
uh you know this this you might say is
the kind of
common thread between the 1992 book
it's the matter with liberalism and the
and the 2018
book so the title what's the matter with
liberalism it's well
the matter is it doesn't have a matter
there's no substance so
it's central to the whole liberal idea
that
you know it doesn't as a political
philosophy dictate
what the what a good life should be it
should be
up to individuals to figure out for
themselves
uh what their good life should be
not the good life for human beings
generally speaking
so there's a kind of moral vacuum on
which
liberalism prides itself that it's to
the credit of liberalism that it creates
space for individuals to figure all that
stuff out for themselves well the
challenge to that
is you know if you leave a vacuum
then you'll get people no we're not
liberals
diving in and dictate and you know
writing the script for what what a good
life should be
and you know arguably both marxists on
one side and
and fascists on the other are supplying
that kind of the
black that for a liberal it's i know
that's part of what liberal that's what
liberalism is meant to be if it's
it's satisfying it's dissatisfying but
that's you know that's the issue there
it goes to the heart of what liberalism
actually intends to be which is we don't
legislate
what the good is you know individuals do
that
job for themselves and you know that can
that creates a a a a a
problem and so when you know nietzsche
says well all you'll get with liberalism
is last men
you know we're just sort of you know
drifting and then
with no idea what their life should be
about and well that's
it's you know uh that's that's that's
that's the normative challenge is that
somebody's going to take responsibility
for this
if you just leave it to individuals
they're just kind of shrug and
you're kind of have cultural vicuity you
know so
um uh
you know i guess the answer to that is
that
uh deep
serious reflection on what the human
good is
is uh not uh dispensable
it's it's it's essential to any proper
human life that there has to
be liberals has to be kind of thicker
and
concerned more with and and certainly
appealing to capitalism it's not gonna
help
that the more you kind of draw
capitalism at the center of what
liberalism is supposed to be that or you
identify liberalism liberal democracy
with capitalism well that's
that's certainly a dead end that that's
not going to help
in in in answering
cultural fundamental cultural challenges
to liberalism
and whether it does or doesn't have
cultural substance so
i would you know for if you if you if
you try to
you know build liberalism back up
normatively
that would not in my view that would not
certainly not be the way to do it you
put as much
distance between the normative appeal of
liberalism
as a political philosophy and capitalism
as a particular economic system
uh uh you know about which islam that's
unattractive
and and that sure that can help
discredit liberalism that's not gonna
if you know you want to defend
liberalism over against
enemies on the right that that would not
uh not be helpful and it's telling that
fascists
including contemporary fascists they're
both anti-liberal and and yeah
you know because capitalism too it's
universalistic
it it you know it's not attentive to
borders between different
uh cultures and different societies and
or nations
and and and that the you know they see
they can easily see liberalism as a sort
of puppet of and again that's kind of
parallel to the marxist view
a puppet of capitalism well i we have
that's why it's so important to go back
to the principles of french revolution
that there is a normative you know
ideal at the heart of uh liberalism or
of
all you know all democracies since um
since the late 18th century that is
the definable separate from capitalism
you know
uh it you know if it liberalism is
doomed normatively speaking
if it's if it's you know tied at the hip
to capitalism i would very strongly
resist that yeah
the liberalism book is is you know it
includes a kind of critique of
capitalism it's you know it's a leftist
book
uh but trying to address the kind of
you know cultural discontent that
liberalism often generates
yeah well it's you know it seems to me
that one of the reasons why maybe
i was just occurring to me why um like
leftists have co-opted nietzsche and
these other figures is maybe because
like they
they can co-op that at least part of it
that part that
observation from nietzsche about like
the current right i think that's why
they find it useful probably the left
right
i i totally agree with that uh i think i
think that's actually a very important
point
so if if your project is to
um uh
discredit liberalism because it's too
closely tied to capitalism
then the question is so who are the most
profound critics of a
broad liberal egalitarian dispensation
that's why you're drawn to nietzsche and
higher they just articulate in a deeper
way
what you know discontents are stirred up
by living in a fundamentally liberal
society
so let's you know our schmidt you know
let's find the
the kind of the you know the deepest
most powerful
most robust rejecters of this liberal
dispensation
so that's why the left i mean it's in
that sense yeah
more uh uh
you know uh more powerful more potent
resources for a leftist project of
discrediting liberalism
that's fine but what if you know once
you've discredited it
it's it you know it's the right that's
in the saddle and not the left and i
think
again that's a more much more serious
problem for us living you know post 2016
uh where the right is on the rise
everywhere and we can't assume well
let's just discredit liberalism and
we'll get some
utopia well in all probability we won't
we may get some
much much worse we'll get our back or
we'll get putin
or we'll get bolsonaro or we'll get modi
in india or we'll get donald trump
uh or we'll get bannon uh you know that
that in that sense this the string of
liberalism is now a kind of
two-edged sword in the way that maybe it
wasn't before this
recent right and far-right revival and
so let's i think have to take that
very seriously so we're going to keep
you know
drawing our you know intellectual
sustenance our resources
from these figures the right well what
if the consequence of that
is the right winds uh can't
assume that liberalism is the worst
thing so if you destroy liberalism
you'll get something better well no you
could get something much worse
and we knew this in the 20th century
then we forgot it and
now we're back to you know perils of
possibly history repeating itself
that brings up that brings up a question
i've had seriously that's why i wrote my
book
probably more than any other reason i'm
wondering
why why in the past has um
i don't know let's say like bourgeois
liberal capitalism or you say
such a worry for it now is is the rise
of the right but in the past
you know capitalism and and sort of
liberalism have been so good at
co-opting counterculture leftism
uh and sort of turning it against itself
right or finding the market for that
sort of thing and then we look at it as
oh it's been co-opted like occupy wall
street
failed um well one cause of disunity but
also because
capitalism is very robust and able to
take blows like that co-opt it find the
market for it and then make those sorts
of sentiments
work for them so now we're all wearing
no-name knock-off vans
and it's a well-known part but with the
right and the far
right capitalism seems to be at a loss
for co-opting that and making it work
for
work for capitalism or maybe it is
co-opting it and then it's
changing capitalism to be more
right-wing and less egalitarian
i don't know maybe that's that that's a
kind of an open-ended question i've been
worried
worrying about as you've been explaining
things
uh i think those are legitimate concerns
and i largely share them i mean
uh you know leftist insights into the
capacity of capitalism to co-opt
challenges to capitalism that's
obviously not a
trivial issue and it should be taken
seriously that's not what my book's
about but i don't
you know uh dismiss any of that uh
and and uh um
you know in terms of occupying victor
probably has more to say about it than i
do
but but i i you know i'm i wouldn't i'm
not i wouldn't push back against the
things you've just said
yeah i'm curious did you want to i just
want to ask one question
actually yeah first off i just wanted to
say how much chris would absolutely
hate uh and my friend said here i was
thinking about that in the debate
between pells and ronnie
but my question is actually we focus a
lot of attention on the nietzsche
controversy and i think we've kind of
not really brought heidi into this in
part because
as you mentioned it's a lot more clear
where his political allegiances
lay but can you explain what the appeal
of heideggerianism
is to the political left and why we
should be
reticent to embrace it and the other
thing that i wanted to talk about is
can one save certain heideggerian
influences uh or insight
from his politics uh i'm thinking of
somebody like dreyfus
and his work on computing so i read his
book uh what computers can't do which is
a heideggerian critique of strong ai
theories uh
and it was very insightful right and a
very creative interpretation of it uh
but you'd be hard-pressed i think to say
that he's carrying any political baggage
uh into the project uh and he still
seems to be getting a lot from that so
i'm just wondering if you could speak to
that
yeah i mean obviously is a very rich
thinker and one can draw all kinds of
things from him
and it for he does provide resources for
articulating in a powerful way things
that are
dissatisfying about modernity and i'm
pretty dissatisfied with modernity
myself so
you know in that sense i've you know
spent my whole adult life
reading and appreciating and learning
from eideger and
you know i don't wouldn't want to toss
that away or say it was
a waste of time or that other people are
wasting their time with heidegger
but i think i think there is a real
parallel with nietzsche
in the following sense that it's too
easy to say well he's
a political he's you know addressing us
as individuals
uh and and and there is there isn't a
political project well i think there is
a political
project and it's i think overlapped
substantiated
nietzsche was a huge inspiration for
heidegger in the late 20s
soon after he published uh uh
uh being in time and it shaped in
a decisive way his engagement in the
early 30s and nietzsche
and heidegger himself says this very
clearly that he probably would not have
been a nazi if not for his reading
of nietzsche and his the impact of what
he felt nietzsche's
fundamental insights to be well you know
bigger too is that that
real culture is hierarchical that
they're they're
it can't just be well you know everybody
figure out for themselves as equal human
beings
what their life is about there has to be
a kind of sense of what kind of
privileged
you know voice of being and you know he
you know his politics are volkish
because it's as as a folk as
as a as a rooted people
that people can hear what being is
saying to them they can't do it as
as individuals but that the voice of
being speaks uh
collectively and that's why his politics
were collectivist
and and focus i mean to some extent it
kind of moved in a
different direction that was radically
different from
nietzsche's but i think the fundamental
problem that they're
obsessed with is pretty much the same i
mean
you know what nietzsche called the reign
of the last man
is what heidegger calls you know
maternity's forgetfulness of being
they're
two vocabularies they're meant to say
the same thing that what modernity
presents us with and this is
has a lot to do with the liberalism and
the egalitarianism modernity what it
presents us with
is a cultural void and they both call
this nihilism
and nihilism is is is requires a new
dispensation
and a new dispensation will have a
political dimension
and you can't just kind of uh arrive at
a new dispensation
individual by individual it happens
civilizationally all cultures go through
a revolution
and you know heidegger thought in the
early 30s germany had gone
through that revolution and it chucked
off you know
the nihilism of democracy the nihilism
of liberalism uh i mean
no these are thinkers are right because
you know for you know heidegger says i
quote in the book
nietzsche's great insight is that
democracy is nihilism
and uh i mean midley said that in the
30s he might have expressed it a little
differently uh you know in later decades
but he when he he actually when he
published the nietzsche lectures in 1960
he took that line out and then when he
put you republished the nietzsche
uh book in his collected works he put
that line back in
that's pretty telling it tells you a lot
about heidegger that he's got his
like nietzsche a view of he's trying to
think not in years or decades he's
thinking in centuries
that over centuries what modernity
offers
us is unsustainable because there's
nothing there culturally
and we have to have our sights set on
some
cultural dispensation centuries hence
when we will have again something that
can compare
with you know the presocratic greeks
i mean that's you know we're it was said
earlier you you can't go back
you have to go forward but you want to
go back to something that's of
equal cultural grandeur to what the
greeks produce that's the standard
and there's no way that liberal
modernity will ever liberal bourgeois
modernity will ever meet that standard
so it has to be rejected
you have to hold out hopes of a
civilization that will meet those
standards and that's
that's what sustains nietzsche and
higher that's their project is to get
back not or not get backboard go forward
to something that replicates
the grandeur capacity to you know
to to um plug into
the voice of being such that we can have
something like what
the greeks had uh and and uh
if you meet that standard you haven't
risen to the heights of what
humanity can be and and that i think is
essential to both nature and heidegger
that's
that's the common commonality between
them and that's why i think hydrogen was
so decisively inspired by nietzsche
and i think we can all agree right
morgan freeman is the real voice of
being
right so ultimately capitalism did
produce
what he was looking for so we
are at currently um an hour
and almost 15 minutes so another round
of
quick questions and quick responses um
if there's anything that's still
lingering if we could uh get to i guess
what's the what's the takeaways that we
should get out of this starting with uh
victor
i think you should have seen by now i'm
not quite capable of quick answers
why i just do our best in steering it
towards a conclusion i believe in you as
the over man to
overcome your own weakness
all right i i wanted to ask uh professor
bienner about i think you you
may have told me about this a while back
but like what was some of the reaction
you got to your book
especially on the right because i think
there's maybe an interesting story there
oh there is there is an interesting
story
uh yeah it kind of really knocked
knocked me off my stride so
the very first um
review of the book it was a very lengthy
review and
respectful and intelligent in all kinds
of ways
uh and intellectually interesting it
came from
someone who is a nazi uh
and i'm not using that in metaphorical
sense that's what he is
he celebrates hitler uh he celebrates
hitler's birthday on his website he's
written defenses of hitler
uh so this is greg johnson has a phd
in philosophy from catholic university
of america's doctoral supervisor is an
old
friend of mine richard welkley i'm sure
pains him now
certainly pains me uh and so he runs
this
site called counter currents and he said
he
uh welcomed the book because it would
help him uh make a case for uh right
nichianism and write heideggerianism
and that uh he found you know the the
book gave a sufficiently
uh convincing case for
nietzsche and heidegger being
fundamentally thinkers are right that
it would be helpful for him in his
campaign to bring back the right
and what the right here means you know
i mean he says he doesn't endorse the
nation the genus
the the genocide and imperialism of of
hitler but
he in a lot of other respects
he's he's he's with hitler and so yeah
that was a big
big shock to me and he uh tweeted it
directly to me
uh with the you know if uh
if if [ __ ] wants a debate with the
alt-right
game on and uh i was pretty shocked by
that i actually wrote a piece
in the chronicle of higher education
articulating them you know my sense of
shock and
and the kind of you know what it says
about
i mean he's a very smart guy and if you
read the review
still on the website uh you know you can
see his intelligence
but he is evil and and
that you know if you've been teaching
political theory
as i have for over 40 years
that's very sobering uh that someone
could go through a kind of humanistic
education
in philosophy and come out the other end
as
a uh as an adherent to hitler
um um so
yeah so that that's got to be very smart
in a way really was a kind of
exclamation point on what the book was
about
yeah that you know the far right yeah
they they're
you know a lot of them are very serious
intellectually um
it's hard to say well how can you how
can you have that kind of politics and
serious intellectually well
you know it's important to be aware that
that is possible
and so they they you know they didn't
lose any time
picking up this book and responding to
it and i think
you know that review was widely read on
the far right and
b
unfortunately you cut out all the bad
parts for them
what do you mean he cut out all the
quotations that are
the most amenable to that position
oh you mean the book assembled like all
the worst quotes nietzsche
kind of like uh his worst hits and
whatnot
i didn't cut that out there i quote
nietzsche
saying that you know no i don't mean you
cut them out i meant they're all
bricolaged
in in order now so that's why it's
helpful to him
yeah so i guess so oh right in the
interest of
um talking to him i was talking to
you know colleagues on the left um
considering myself of the left that you
know you better take another look at
this
if you think that nietzsche is a voice
for progressivism
uh and think harder about you know
who your intellectual sources are and uh
um yeah i mean i
you know i think nietzsche himself and i
think this goes for heidegger too
nietzsche would be utterly shocked
that he would come be received with you
know with bio and open
with open arms by by the left by people
who are you know radical egalitarians
i need to be scratching his head how
could they read these books
and think that he's with them he's not
well what do you say you know above all
don't misunderstand me
right but uh actually i had a question
okay matt we have to wrap up
if anything so if as long as it's a
wrap-up question
yeah i've got a pop-up question too i
think
that's why i know it's a very quick one
um it's just uh
corey robin in his book the reactionary
mind which i quite admire i have
problems with it but it's very good
uh points out something that you point
out as well which is that there's always
this temptation uh
on the part of many leftists or liberals
uh to assume that people on the far
right are just
unintelligent prejudiced uh you know
kind of
ref right you know roughnecks uh and
that's a cliche that we need to dispel
and robin goes through his book and says
you know if you look at these guys
whether you're talking about your carl
schmitz uh
or your iron rands or your heights you
know they have a lot of interesting
provocative things to say that attracts
intelligent people
uh and i'm wondering why do you think
some intelligent people
educated people however you want to
frame it are attracted to these
far-right doctrines
uh just again very briefly if possible
uh well i've already warned you that i
don't give short answers and
you know i i i think through much of the
conversation we've already had i've been
addressing
just those things i mean if you're if
you're looking for
uh uh
powerful ideas uh and
and ideas that are you know socratic in
the sense of
you know a a a radical attempt to
depart the cave of
you know contemporary society however
you define that cave
these thinkers supply that and it's on
accident that
nietzsche you know nobody heard nobody
knew who nietzsche was
and the 20th century's been utterly
dominant and same for heidegger
it's not an accident it's not an
accident when people develop those kinds
of followings
and there there is something uh that
has a lot of force and and but but
just because they're powerful thinkers
doesn't mean
they will improve the world they can
make the world much worse
and we have to be sensitive to that and
there's there is a kind of
you know uh important distinction
between
uh what a thinker has to offer
intellectually and
what it might do to our civic life and
and
you know we're not just thinkers we're
also citizens and we have to be
sensitive to both sides
um you know i could have just gone on
reading nietzsche
as i did in my youth and and not worry
about the civic implications of
nietzsche
but you know at this moment you know i'd
say in a sense i wrote the book because
my
my sense of civic responsibility trump
my um
you know the kind of luxury of just
being an intellectual for the sake of
being intellectual
and uh again as i said at the start this
was a citizen's book
all right uh eric's got one thing to
wrap up on
and then we'll say thanks so this is
this is just the sort of future
recommendations like okay so where do we
go from here
uh so i just want to contrast this with
uh another thinker we covered i don't
know if you've heard of joram hazoni
uh he's he's a religious uh conservative
philosopher or thinker maybe from from
israel
and he yeah he worries about the rise of
marxism that's that's sort of his main
worry and the way he frames it is that
what the left has to do the moderate
left has to do
is ally with the right in order to bring
down this sort of far left
this rise of the far left and turn in
the postmodern
cultural marxism all all that stuff that
all that stuff that peterson complains
about
peterson's gonna float out there and and
he says that the
the the left wing needs to ditch the far
left because it's just pulling moderate
leftists
further to the left because they keep
having to compromise and make
adjustments to their own position and
eventually they'll end up marxist
themselves this is hazoni's
and they'll be the end of liberal
democracy is the one yeah yeah this is
the
last so he sees the end of it coming
from from the left
from within the left it's going to
destroy itself but you have a different
kind of recommendation
your your recommendation at the end of
your book
is and you include a list of
anti-liberal theorists here rousseau
marx and joseph de maestra along with
uh nietzsche and heidegger but your your
recommendation is basically that
that yes we should engage with these
thinkers but no
we shouldn't ignore their nasty bits we
shouldn't whitewash them
we shouldn't um make them we shouldn't
make them
agree with the way we think if we are
liberal thinkers
because we're going to get you say
sucker punched
by their sort of nastier ideas when
people bring those out and say well what
about
this way of what nietzsche says what
about heidegger so maybe you could just
in your own words maybe
uh say what your own sort of conclusion
or recommendation was
in your book
well yeah that was not a short question
it was quite a long question about that
it doesn't really uh
you know it's hard to see how i could
give a short answer to it
political program i mean i'm a theorist
i'm not a political actor
and not mapping out some agenda
i think we just have to uh you know
and aaron said think what we're doing we
have to be more intellectually
reflective about the society we're
living in and the potential heralds of
that society
um zoni i've read some of his other work
i haven't read the book on nationalism
very wary about it and i mean he's been
embraced by trumpites because he's
pro-nationalist
and they see trump's fundamental project
as a nationalist
project i that's project to the right
and
i i think you know liberals who sought
to
ally themselves with hozoni or anything
associated with that
i think would that would be very
misguided um
but you know i'm not having read the
book i
i can't really you know get into a
dialogue
with him but you know he i you're right
he
i think the project there he has a very
definite project
of could very conservative nationalism
uh
i i don't have a project at an
alternative to that
um uh i'm i'm just trying to
you know say well you know the red
lights are flashing here
and we're ours and and our
citizenship as members of a liberal
democratic society are
uh is very much you know in in jeopardy
and and the stakes are extremely high
and people have to kind of wake up the
citizens
and realize how much is at stake uh i
think that
i've kind of you know limit my
prescriptions to that
uh rather than pull something out of my
back pocket and say well
here's the kind of politics that will
save us i mean hopefully other people
can do that
uh i don't see that as something i would
attempt and uh
you know i think in terms of political
programs i'd be
too modest to attempt to attempt such a
thing
that's great thank you but he's
different he he definitely has an idea
of what
right politics are and and i would say
not that
great well is that are we good then
should we wrap up
yeah um well ron sorry for getting a
little testy in the in the middle
there oh that's fine it's it's socratic
socratic debate i appreciate it
thanks so much if you're interested in
what ron's been talking about
ronnie oh excuse me excuse me
the book is called uh dangerous minds
is it mostly on heidegger and nietzsche
or is there other people included in
there too
the meat of the book is nietzsche and
heidegger yeah nietzsche and heidegger
are the core of it
so if you want to and he never says
don't read them but he says read them
with uh
your antennas up i guess um
so yeah thanks everyone for watching if
you're still watching
i i don't know if this is on youtube or
if it's on podcast yet
and if you're still listening we'll
figure it out um
but stay tuned for uh future content and
thank you so much ronnie
uh my pleasure is a lot of fun thanks so
much all right bye everyone
thank you bye-bye all right i'm gonna
pause it here
[Music]
cool
you